Hi there.
My name's Alice.
And this is Making Polymer
Elements Accessible.
So you've gotten
the Web Components
bug and downloaded Polymer.
And you've made your
first custom element.
Fantastic.
Today I'm here to
talk a bit about how
we can make sure
our brand new custom
elements can be
used by everyone.
Right now, built-in
HTML5 elements
work well for accessibility.
This didn't happen by accident.
Browser developers follow
published standards
for ensuring the accessibility
of these elements
and add keyboard
handling, styling,
and semantic
information to make sure
that all users can use them.
When we're creating new
components for the web,
ideally they should be
using the same standards.
They, too, should be
accessible to all users.
When we talk about
all users, there
are several broad
classes of impairment
that we consider--
visual impairment, which
could range from poor color
vision through low vision,
to no vision; hearing
issues, whether a user is
deaf, hard-of-hearing, or
simply can't use the device's
audio output; mobility
or motor impairment,
whether temporary or permanent,
such as a broken arm, RSI,
or long-term motor disorder;
other impairments which
encompass a very broad
range of issues, including
cognitive impairments like
dyslexia, ADHD, brain injury,
and other impairments like
learning disorder, epilepsy,
and vestibular disorder.
The first thing
we want to look at
is whether an element can be
used with the keyboard alone.
This is the first
step ensuring it
can be used by users
of assistive technology
on all platforms.
But also important for users
with motor impairments,
or injuries, or any
desktop users who
can't or won't use
a mouse right now.
During your
user-experience design,
think about how you would use
your element with a keyboard
alone and figure
out a consistent set
of keyboard interactions.
To help with the design
process, consider
including physical impairments
in your user experience
personas.
If you're creating an element
which mimics an existing
element in some way,
consider copying
the way it handles keyboard
interactions to provide
consistency.
Try using a native
element with the keyboard
and find out what already works.
Chances are, you've been using
the keyboard sometimes anyway.
So you'll find it
comes pretty naturally.
Later, we'll talk
about ARIA, which
allows you to specify additional
semantics for your element.
Once you've picked
a semantic role,
you can use the
ARIA design patents
guide to get some
extra advice on what
keyboard events to handle.
The first step in
actually implementing
keyboard interactions is to
make sure the element can
take keyboard focus.
Unless you can actually
focus on the element,
it's not going to get
any keyboard events.
Ensure you have a sensible
focus target for your element.
For a simple element
like a button,
this will obviously just
be the element itself.
A complex element like a
menu-- maybe one focused target
within the page, but then
manage focus within itself.
So the active menu item
always takes focus.
In this case you
want to make sure
that the menu items are
programmatically focusable,
but not in the tab order itself.
This is where an understanding
of the nuances of the tabIndex
attribute is going
to come in handy.
TabIndex can take one of
three classes of values.
When tabIndex is
zero, the element
will be in the natural
tab order which
is defined by the DOM order.
This is what you would
use to make a custom
element, such as a custom
button, keyboard focusable.
When tabIndex is
negative, the element
will be programmatically
focusable but not in the tab
order.
This would be
useful for something
like the menu example
on the previous slide.
The menu container
element can manage
setting focus to each individual
menu item when appropriate.
The tabIndex is
greater than zero,
the element will be
in a manual tab order.
This makes no sense in the
context of Web Components,
since you essentially never know
where your event-- your element
will fall on the page.
So now that you've spec'd out
your keyboard interactions
and made your element
focusable, you'll
need to implement the actual
keyboard interactions.
Luckily, there's an
event handler for that.
You can add an on-key data
attribute to your Polymer
element and add a method to
handle the keyboard event,
checking for any key-press
events you're interested in.
Finally, make sure your keyboard
interactions are discoverable,
especially if they're not using
one of the standard patents.
Tool tips or keyboard
help overlays
are common patterns
for achieving this.
Once our keyboard
interactions are working,
we're a good part of
the way there already.
Next, we need to take a look
at whether our element can
be used with
assistive technology.
The types of users who would
use assistive technology
range from users with
visual impairments
who might use screen
readers or braille displays;
to users with
cognitive impairments
such as dyslexia, who might
use a screen reader to augment
their reading ability; and
users with motor impairments
who need to use
technologies like voice
control to interact
with their devices.
There are really only
two parts to ensuring
that your element can be used
with assistive technology,
including screen readers,
once you've addressed keyboard
accessibility-- adding
semantic information,
including the element's
role, state, value, and name,
and making sure that
all information conveyed
visually has a text alternative.
First, let's talk
about semantics.
One of the great things
about custom elements
is that they make a mark-up
look semantic again.
We can hide presentation
logic inside the shadow DOM
and use meaningful element
names to create a readable DOM.
However, assistive technology
doesn't see those semantics.
It still sees
essentially DIV soup,
unless you tell it about the
semantics you want your element
to have.
Assuming we're not
extending built-in elements,
the way we tell
assistive technology
about these additional
semantics is
using WAI-ARIA,
or ARIA for short.
ARIA is a specification
defining support
for accessible-rich
web applications.
It defines mock-up
extensions implemented
as attributes and
elements, which
can be used to provide
additional information
about the semantics of elements
to assistive technologies
like screen readers.
This is what using ARIA
looks like in vanilla HTML5.
So we can use ARIA to add
the semantic information
we want to our custom elements.
This is a custom slider
element which you can visually
see as a minimum value of
one, a maximum value of five,
and a current value of 2.5.
Until we add the
relevant ARIA attributes,
though, this element doesn't
communicate any of these
to assistive technology.
We can add ARIA value attributes
to tell assistive technology
about the value of this element.
Here we have added
the attributes
for role and current
minimum and maximum values.
Finally, once all your
semantics are in place,
make sure you always
have text alternatives
for any other information
which is conveyed visually.
For example, if your custom
button uses a settings icon,
make sure you give it a
name of settings as well.
And obviously make
sure all of your images
have an alt attribute.
Even if you want
them to be skipped
by assistive technology.
Assistive technology will try
to come up with alternative text
if you don't provide it.
And often it'll
pick the file name.
So provide an
empty alt attribute
if you want the image to
be visible to assistive
technology.
We also need to
make sure that users
of any form of color
blindness can use our element.
Firstly, let's make
sure that we're not
communicating anything
with color alone.
Color shouldn't be
used as the only means
of conveying information
such as indicating a status,
prompting for a response, or
distinguishing a visual custom
element.
Here we have the
Chromium dashboard
which, as well as being
a Polymer application,
gives the status
for each new web
platform feature being developed
or shipped in Chromium.
Since the color dots
next to the stakeholders
are meant to convey
information, the developers
added a tool tip
here which appears
when you hover over the name
giving the same information.
We also need to make
sure that there's always
sufficient contrast between text
or icons and background color.
This is important for
users with low vision
who might have trouble
reading low-contrast text,
color blind users in
the case where we're
using two different
colors next to each other,
and any user using
a mobile phone
or device in bright sunlight.
Any text content
displayed in your element
should at least meet the minimum
contrast ratio of 4.5 to one.
You can audit your element
for sufficient contrast using
the accessibility developer
tools extension, which
even provides suggested
foreground and background color
pairs if it finds
low-contrast text.
Lastly, make sure any
moving or flashing content
is stoppable and safe.
If you have any fancy, slidey
parallax-y transitions,
make sure you have a
way to turn those off.
They can be a real pain for
people with vestibular disorder
who may experience
motion sickness
symptoms while using them.
And if you have any flashing
content-- please don't tell me
you're re-implementing
the blink tag--
make sure it meets the criteria
for safe flashing content
of having a flash frequency
of three times per second,
or fewer.
So let's recap and summarize
everything into a handy list.
Remember, every
built-in HTML5 element
will have all of these
properties, at least
in a mainstream browser.
So we should make sure the
custom elements do, too.
Make sure that your element can
be used with a keyboard alone.
Make sure that it works
with assistive technology.
Make sure that it
doesn't rely on color
to communicate
important information.
Make sure all text and icons
have sufficient contrast
ratio with the background.
Make sure that it
works without sound.
I didn't cover
this, but make sure
any video or audio elements
have the appropriate text
alternatives.
And make sure you aren't
relying on audio cues
to prompt for actions.
And finally, make sure any
moving or flashing content
is configurable and safe.
Please check out our article
on the Polymer project website,
which goes into more detail on
much of what I've covered here
as well as providing links to
many other useful resources.
Remember, we're creating
new components for the web.
We have an amazing
opportunity to make
sure the web is
accessible for everyone.
Let's do this.